my name is pax heymeyer
i am the director of academic programs
and the manager of the stanford advanced
computer security program
here at the stanford center for
professional development
and it is uh my pleasure to be hosting
dan binney and neil de swani today
as they give us the landscape of the
cyber security market
and help you understand that landscape
in order to build
a comprehensive security solution for
your organization
so with that let me introduce our
presenters today dan binet is the
co-director of the stanford advanced
computer security program and professor
in computer science and electrical
engineering
here at stanford he heads the applied
cryptography group and co-directs the
computer security lab here
he is the recipient of multiple awards i
won't go into into all of them but
i do want to also emphasize that he's a
really innovative educator and not just
for the online programs he's developed
with us but he also has a mooc on
cryptography
as well as an online textbook available
at cryptobook.us
that's a graduate level textbook on
cryptography
at cryptobook.us it's freely available
and i
believe he'll be doing a new update on
that book in january
it is also my pleasure to introduce neil
desjuani neil is also the co-director of
the stanford advanced computer security
program
he is an accomplished technical
visionary angel investor and internet
security leader who has served in a
variety of research development
teaching and executive roles for example
he was the chief information security
officer at lifelock
and at symantec's consumer business unit
he is also the co-author of an upcoming
book on big breaches which will be
coming out in early 2021
as well as foundations of security what
every programmer needs to know which is
which has been out um and is an
excellent book i i've read it
so with that i am going to go ahead and
hand
the uh the webinar over to neil and
dan great thank you very much pax
so let me first by start off by saying
that cyber security has become
a huge market a large market uh
irrespective of which industry analysts
you look at whether it's gartner or idc
uh there's over a hundred billion
dollars that gets spent per year
on cyber security solutions the field is
growing at a
nine to ten percent uh growth rate some
areas faster than others
uh you can see that there are some areas
here in managed security services that
are in fact growing at
fourteen point two percent uh other
areas at ten percent and whatnot
there's even some entry analysts that
expect that the market will be a 300
billion dollar market by 2024 which
which is a little bit aggressive
uh there are over 3
900 companies in the cyber security
space that have been funded over the
past 15 years
there's just some of them that are shown
on this diagram here for momentum cyber
this particular slide divides up the
cyber security landscape into about
18 or so categories it's not the only
way to divide it up but thing to take
away from this slide
is that there are lots of companies the
space
is generally quite fragmented um and
there's a lot of
mergers and acquisition type activity
and it can chat more about that at the
end of the
presentational way of time there's no
way to cover the entire cyber security
landscape
in this one hour presentation but what
we'll do
is we'll cover five to six of the
categories and talk about some examples
within each
so with that to start us off let's uh
but i'll turn it over to dan who will
tell us about identity and access
management
yeah thank you um so welcome everyone
first of all thanks all for joining us
this should be a fun
fun hour and we're happy to take
questions and discuss with you
these uh these topics at the at the end
of the hour um so
let's see so like neil said the security
space is vast and huge there's just a
huge number of companies
and even as you can see from this from
the diagram a very large number of
categories
and so what we decided to do is just
focus on a few categories that
um that well that we're kind of excited
about
and tell you about a few things that are
happening in that space
so the first one we wanted to start with
is identity and access management
so let's start just by kind of reviewing
a few
um a few kind of uh issues in that space
so what is what is identity
and access management so already you can
see from the diagram here
on the upper right there is a fair
number of companies in the space
you can kind of break it up into into
even some categories
so for example there are a number of
companies that provide services like
identity as a service
so that you outsource your identity um
questions to these companies and so
companies like octa duo and rsa i think
everybody's familiar with those
there are companies that provide second
factor tokens like yubiko and fight and
and fashion and rsa and so on um
and then there are companies that
provide uh general access management
either for kind of here is where the
market kind of bifurcates there are
companies that focus
on access management for employees these
are the iim companies
and there are companies that focus on
identity and access management
customers so those kind of products
allow for self-registration
and more importantly kind of
self-service functionality so that's
kind of a high-level view
of the space what i wanted to talk a
little bit about are some new things
that are happening in the space
so specifically i want to focus on
second factor tokens
one thing that's happened recently is um
well i kind of
if you can see on the bottom bottom
right here i i
listed some pictures of of a number of
tokens one thing that's happened is a
lot of these companies have added
support for nfc
to their tokens which is kind of cool in
that now you can use these tokens
not just by plugging them into your
laptop but you can also use them with
your phone
connect to your phone through nfc and
then do the authentication so i kind of
listed
multiple products in the space that
support nfc so you can do authentication
on your phone so that's one thing that's
kind of happened
just basically a broader support for
second factor tokens
i didn't want to bring up the fact that
the second factor tokens are extremely
extremely important and so there's this
really
kind of um well-regarded um
you know announcement that google made a
few years ago i guess back in 2017
saying that you know they kind of
distributed
these tokens throughout their user base
throughout their employee base
and as a result there have been
basically no phishing attacks on
google employees basically since 2017
this is kind of a remarkable achievement
so this does say something about the
power of these uh second factor tokens
so i i again i wanted to talk about a
few things that have kind of happened in
the space and so
one interesting development with second
factor tokens are these
is this uh web of end in ctap standards
so i hope you can read the font here
it's a little small but basically what
web of 10 does
is it brings second factor
authentication with
grid's navy support native support for
second factor authentication to the web
in particular it adds in browser
javascript support
for interacting with the second factor
tokens so effectively
um the the authentication so when you
connect to a remote website
authentication is done using a second
factor token that you hold in your hand
you can plug it into your
computer or or connect you connect it to
your computer via nfc
it also supports browser-based long-term
secrets that can be used
for authenticating users to remote
websites so basically this is kind of a
way to provide
um much better challenge response uh
authentication protocols for web remote
websites so if your website
has a need for remote authentication
definitely look into integrating it with
web both and
either you would do it yourself or you
would do it through through um
you know the identity as a service
providers like duo and octa that already
work with web of them in fact one of the
nice websites that explains how web on
works is due to dual
um just i wanted to show you how this
works so this is quite widely supported
and all the major browsers chrome
firefox
edge and safari support is is coming um
and so you can even look at this
canius.com website which shows you which
web features are supported
by which browsers you'll see it's
actually quite widely supported
and again i just wanted to drill into
the details a little bit basically way
both line supports two steps there's a
registration process
there's an authentication process and
all that is done through the browser so
in fact
there's a browser object called
navigator.credential.create
that lets you create credentials for a
user your website that lets you create
credentials
on the user's browser and then there's
the when you want to do authentication
there's a navigator
credentials.get.financial.get
which allows the browsers to use the
credentials that you created yeah and
like i said
you can kind of integrate these things
yourself into your website or you can
use duo or octa
to do to do the integration for you and
again the point is to move away from sms
to these much better second factor
authentication systems that like we said
support challenge response which is
a better way to do authentication so
that's what i wanted to talk about
for web authen there's one more thing
that i wanted to mention in the
authentication space
specifically about password management
this is kind of a very cute thing that
rolled out that google rolled out
recently
so i just wanted to mention and make
sure you know about this so the problem
is the following
google was able to me to obtain a very
large
set of compromised passwords as you know
there are
um large data sets of compromise
passwords constantly being discovered
and you can go and buy those uh those uh
password databases so google kind of has
a very large set
um of compromise passwords passwords
like one two three four five six and
abc123
hopefully here nobody nobody here uses
those passwords and if you are using
those one of those passwords
please go ahead and change that right
away anyhow what they wanted to do was
allow
uh the their browser to basically uh
enable the user to test whether their
password where the user's password
has been compromised so when the user
types in a password
on um into the browser in the password
field what's
the chrome browser and now other
browsers too what they will
automatically do
um or what they would like to do is they
would like to send the user's password
to uh to google so that google can check
whether the
password has been compromised then
google would respond back saying
no this com password has not been
compromised or if or it has and if it
has been compromised
then the browser immediately alerts the
user to change to go ahead and change
their password so this is kind of a
pretty nice capability to have but if
you think about this for a week for a
second you realize this is a pretty bad
idea
because effectively you the user will be
sending all their passwords to google
which is not something we want right
if i have a password with a random
website i don't want that password
being sent to google for even if it's
done for uh for
good purposes so the question was how do
you implement a system like this
and here is where uh interesting uh
conflicts between privacy
and security come up right from a
security point of view we'd like to send
our password
but from a password from a privacy point
of view we cannot
and so the question is how to resolve
that attention and so this
system was actually deployed using very
clever cryptography using techniques
called private information retrieval
which allows you to test whether an item
is in a remote database without ever
telling the remote database
what you're actually testing for yeah so
this is kind of cool
in that you can now test whether your
password is in the remote database
without ever revealing to google what
your password is
yeah so if you want to read more about
how this works you know i have the link
down here
um and so this was kind of a cute uh
deployment of cryptography that happened
recently and i wanted you to be aware
that this is something that uh
basically uh the public now has uh
available for use okay so i'll stop here
and hand it over to neil
great thank you dan so i'm gonna
continue by talking about the next
category
which is internet of things security uh
for those of you that
haven't heard the term internet of
things before all i expect most of you
have
you know i i'll tell you i first started
hearing this term around
2011 2012 sometime in that range
and it basically refers to the the
billions of
devices that are coming online on the
internet that are not
servers or laptops or mobile phones
if we think about uh all the devices in
our homes these days
webcams doorbell cams uh amazon alexas
uh nest thermostats uh all kinds of
devices that plug into your home
automation system whether they be
sensors
like smoke alarms or whether they be
devices
that do something based on sensor data
like light bulbs
uh there's expected to be you know 20
billion of these types of devices
uh deployed by 2025. there's only eight
billion
people expected to be on the face of the
earth by 2025 so that's that's a
significant number of
devices now these devices have
typically been engineered to be as
low cost as possible uh and even if
security has been a design criterion for
some of them it typically has not been
the
highest priority and so as a result
there's
tons of these iot devices that
perhaps cannot even be patched you know
if there's a
security vulnerability found in the code
that runs on these devices
it may not even be possible to update
the code
so that the device is now not vulnerable
even if the device is capable of being
patched
uh it may not get patched regularly uh
because these devices are also deployed
by
end users uh you know your average
everyday
uh folk they they they may not uh
configure those devices they may
leave the default password in place and
you know there have been
botnets like mirai that have infected
hundreds of thousands of these machines
and sent traffic to netflix and twitter
and basically knocked out those sites
for some period of hours because because
of
these these vulnerabilities there's in
general
a lack of security standards in the
internet of things space
so as compared to for instance when you
buy
any other electrical device there's
typically a
sign off from underwriter labs and a tag
that you can see on the device
there there is no similar safety or
security certification
that's become very widespread in the
internet of things space
although there are a few or a few uh you
know
things coming up in that so in any case
uh this is what iot security
is is all about how do we secure all
these devices
and how do we secure all of the
implications
that can result from these devices
getting getting
impacted by malware or other things so
if we think about what's new in this
space well
earlier this year we went from a
scenario where
maybe sixteen percent of all workers
were remote and beautiful 19
you know 90 95 percent of people were
required to
to work from home and even even you know
when
the world returns to some semblance of
more normalcy
the expectation is that there's still
going to be many more remote workers
than
than there was before now how does that
have anything to do with iot security
well
you've got you've got people working at
home they've got their corporate devices
now on their
on their home network and they also
uh have a lot of these iot devices their
their amazon alexas and other devices on
their home network some of which
some of which could be vulnerable and
could get hacked i'll tell you just
a few weeks ago my firewall at home
started giving me alerts because
my dvr that records all the footage from
my home cameras
was under attack by a botnet and of
course the first thing i did is i
i just shut the thing down because it's
okay if my cameras don't work for a few
hours but i definitely don't want my
home network
to get hacked and now that my my
corporate device is
running in that home network um
attackers can
compromise iot devices in the home and
then use those
to attack corporate laptops or other
corporate corporate resources so so the
question is how do we how do we protect
all these corporate devices from iot
devices
the other challenge that companies have
is that you can't necessarily trust the
home routers because
they could still have default passwords
they could have their
dns hacked the service that translates
domain names to ip addresses and
once the attacker takes that it's kind
of game over so there have been
a whole bunch of new solutions that have
uh started entering the market
um you know companies like cyberx and
whatnot they basically give
enterprises um tools so they can
they can manage the internet of things
devices either in their enterprises or
potentially otherwise the concept of
zero trust has also been an important
concept uh
in in the field in which uh it used to
be the case that you used to rely on an
internet or some corporate uh network
and once somebody was on the corporate
network you can assume that
you know it's secure and whatnot but the
concept of zero trust says no that's not
the right way to look at this instead of
relying on some perimeter network and
there's inevitably going to be
compromised devices in any network the
the concept of xero trust says you know
what let's not trust any of the devices
let's every time that a device or a user
connects in
let's uh authenticate the uh user's
identity let's authenticate the device
and only let it on the network if we can
confirm that
um that it can be trusted but you gotta
verify every time you don't trust
something
just because it happens to be on the
network so the question is how can we
how can we set up
a environment in people's homes where
they can work more security
given the fact that there's threats from
these iot devices and given the fact
that we'd like to have zero trust so
there's solutions like
bios that have come out recently where
it's a
piece of hardware that you stick into
your laptop
it basically relies on your home router
only for transport
it does not even rely on your home
router for dns to convert domain names
to ip addresses
and basically takes your corporate
device and puts it on a micro segment
of one so whereas the home network used
to typically just be
flat and any device on the network could
communicate with any other device in the
network
once you stick in a bios device in your
corporate uh into your corporate laptop
it segments it off so that nothing on
your corporate on your home network can
even communicate
so anyhow that's iot security and some
of the some of the new
solutions coming out given what's been
going on in the world
with that i'll hand it over back over to
dan chat about cloud security
great thanks neil so i i see that
already
a number of questions coming in which is
great so keep uh keep the questions
coming in and where we'll discuss those
uh
at the end of uh at the end of the
presentation um so yeah so we're gonna
like we said there are many sectors
in the security space we're kind of uh
moving through these sectors pretty
quickly
the next sector we wanted to talk about
uh is cloud security
and so again cloud security is a pretty
large topic with lots and lots of
companies in the space
in fact we're putting together a whole
course right now a whole online course
for the program just on uh cloud
security
and how to manage your containers uh in
the cloud well and so on
but if i can break the space into kind
of three high-level categories
well obviously there's the cloud at the
caspe providers the cloud access
security brokers
these are companies that basically
provide tools that sit between the cloud
user and the cloud provider
and they basically provide policy
monitoring and enforcement
and how to properly use these tools is
kind of a pretty interesting question in
its own right
which we'll talk about in a second uh
there's a whole bunch of companies
looking at continuous security so making
sure that the code that you upload to
the cloud
actually does what it's supposed to do
and is hardened in one way or another
and there are again that sector breaks
into folks who do external monitoring of
the
containers so external scanning of
containers to make sure everything is
configured properly
or even internal monitoring where they
provide tools that sit inside of the
container
and then there are approaches that are
kind of exciting
uh to me personally which is kind of uh
what what we call enclave
based cloud security where basically all
the the cloud would provide an enclave
like capability so this would be like a
hardware component where all your all
your containers in the cloud
run inside of this hardware component
and no cloud administrator can see
into the component yeah so it's kind of
either dedicated hardware or maybe
on-ship hardware
but the point is you have a hardware
firewall that prevents
anyone from looking into what's
happening inside of this hardware
container
and so the the interesting the promising
uh vision here
is that you could actually give jobs to
the cloud you can upload a container to
the cloud
the cloud would only see encrypted data
so all your customer data all your
business data
would always be encrypted in the cloud
the only place where it gets decrypted
in the cloud is when it's inside of this
container
but like we said the container is
protected from the outside world
using using uh hardware so this is kind
of an interesting vision
where well that will be moving to um as
soon as this is available
which basically allows you to kind of
outsource jobs to the cloud
but minimizing the trust that you put in
the in the cloud
um okay so that's kind of uh uh roughly
how
the cloud security space breaks uh into
into the different sectors
i wanted to tell you a little bit about
some recent research that um
that we did that may be relevant to
things that you're you're concerned
about
so the specific problem i wanted to tell
you about is what's called the question
of key rotation in the cloud
yeah so what is the problem well so you
know we all have lots of data we all
manage lots of data
we'd rather not keep the data on our own
premises or even in our business
premises we'd rather up
upload the data to the cloud but then
when we uploaded the
data to the cloud if the cloud doesn't
need to actually operate on this data
we'd rather encrypt the data so that the
cloud doesn't actually see the data in
the clear and then we keep the key
to ourselves now there's this operation
called the standard operation on
encrypted data is called key rotation
yeah which basically means periodically
re-encrypt the data under a new key yeah
and this is a good
hygiene idea this is a good idea to do
let's say once a year or so
you would re-encrypt all your data and
then everything gets deep
re-encrypted under a new key so now the
old key
effectively becomes useless and of
course we're assuming here that the
cloud itself is trusted to delete the
old ciphertext
so that the rotation actually does
really
make sure that the old key is no longer
useful for anything
okay so that's called key rotation so
why do we do key rotation
well basically what it says is you know
if you have a contract or that you hired
into your organization and you gave them
keys
to your data well once they leave and
you do a key rotation
the key that you give them is no longer
viable yeah so this is a way to sort of
revoke
key even though you gave it to someone
and you might not be able to take the
key back
you basically make the key be useless
for that person yeah so
again that's one reason to do key
rotation it's kind of a good idea in its
own right it's like a periodic
key rotation it's also required by a
number of standards yeah so i listed a
couple of standards out there
that have built-in requirements for
either annual or semi-annual key
rotation
on all your data just to make sure your
keys are fresh at any given time
but when you try to do key rotation in
the cloud you very quickly run into a
problem
right if you want to rotate data in the
cloud well how do you do it right so
the the the you have the keys the cloud
has the data so how do you actually
re-encrypt the data
so the obvious apps uh us option is to
just download the entire data from the
cloud
re-encrypted on-prem and then upload the
new ciphertext back to the cloud
that is horrendously expensive because
now you have to download all your data
and re-encrypt and re-upload so the
networking costs are going to be quite
quite high for this especially if you
have a lot of data
of course the other option is to send
the old key to the cloud send a new key
to the cloud and then allow the cloud to
do the re-encryption itself
but of course by doing this you just
gave the cloud access to all your data
which is what we were trying to avoid in
the first place yeah so you see key
rotation
in the cloud is kind of problematic
because the both naive solutions
are impractical for one reason or
another so
uh what we were interested in is
basically a practical way to do this
and so there's a there's a different way
to encrypt data it's called what's
called updatable encryption
there are a number of papers uh on this
that have appeared recently
and so let me just explain to you what
it does the idea is that
again the cloud the data lives encrypted
in the cloud as you can see on the right
and on the left the customer the client
cloud customer basically has the old key
and the new key
what the cloud customer does is he they
can somehow combine the old key in
the new key into some mixed up key yeah
so this is like a nonsense key
that reveals nothing about the old key
and the new key by itself
you can send this update key this is
what's called the encryption update key
you can send that over to the cloud
that tells nothing the cloud learns
nothing about the old key or the new key
but that kind of mixed up key allows the
cloud to re-encrypt your data to do the
rotation
so the amazing thing here is the cloud
can do rotation but the cloud learns
nothing
about the data that gets you encrypted
so yes so very little communication
and you're maintaining security so it
resolves the problem that uh we just
mentioned with with key rotation
so what can we do there well so i linked
to sort of a paper that we put out on
how to do this if you
want to read more about this and about
about the state of the art in the space
uh the main point i wanted to point out
is there are kind of reasonably
efficient constructions to do this
one um one construction is called the
nested construction which is
particularly uh practical
and if this is something that you're
worried about then um in fact this is
something
that is available to implement to
implement so if you're this is something
that's interesting to you
you know feel free to reach out and i
would be happy to discuss these kind of
uh issues with you okay so i will stop
here
and we'll move on to the next sector and
i'll hand it back to neil
great thank you dan i'm gonna now chat a
little bit about application security
uh application security is a category
that's probably been around for i don't
know
20 years or so sometimes it's called
software security
but the idea is that if you are a
company
or any organization that develops
software of your own
uh you've got to make sure that your own
software is not
vulnerable to all kinds of
uh issues ranging from cross-site
scripting
sql injection to buffer overflows uh
there's been a whole bunch of different
types of vulnerabilities and
application security is all about
preventing detecting and eliminating
uh such a software vulnerability so i'm
just going to go through a few examples
of what application security about and
you know i'm
a big fan of whenever you can design
security into your systems
such that vulnerabilities are not
possible or highly unlikely that that's
all the better and so for instance
if you look at what google did for
instance
uh they basically designed a
middleware web templating framework
that pretty much all their engineers and
developers use
such that uh vulnerability
like cross-site scripting and sql
injection are
nearly impossible uh to to happen and so
the way these things work is for those
of you that say aren't familiar with
cross-site scripting
uh it's problem where when a user
provides input to a website a a user
could you know put in characters or
whatnot
that when echoed back by the website um
confused the browser into executing code
that the site itself did not initially
intend
to to execute but basically if
when such data is output back out to a
browser it is
uh output escaped and converted into
uh data uh and cannot be interpreted as
code
it basically makes makes such attacks
uh and such attack attempts inert so so
whenever you can design in
um things like that it's it's uh it's
better i provided a reference to
a great talk that christophe kern of
google uh called her
i first spoke uh you know gave on this
particular topic
you know that said whenever whenever you
can't use such a such a framework to
make such
vulnerabilities nearly impossible you
can do a number of things uh you can run
a number of tests on your code
to see whether or not it might be
vulnerable one example of such
tests are static analysis tests
and such tests look at the code without
running it and try to identify
vulnerabilities so
coverity is an example of a
startup that came out of stanford
research years ago
uh dawson engler and team where they
were
able to identify such types of
vulnerabilities
without even running the code you know
another
example is dynamic analysis
where basically you run the code to
you you run it in a sandbox or a test
environment
in such a way that you can exercise code
paths
pipe in malicious input and see what
happens and how the code reacts and if
it ends up doing something say
unexpected
as a result uh so that's uh das or
dynamic analysis
uh uh security testing uh ias is another
acronym that's entered the field and
that is uh interactive application
security testing and the idea there is
that if you have a bunch of
unit cases unit test cases or regression
test cases
you can basically run those on the code
and
try to poke and prod the code into
demonstrating a vulnerability
so by the way uh tin foil is an example
of a company that
did some great dynamic analysis and
actually both tin foil
and coverity got acquired by synopsis
synopsis
while they were traditionally a you know
a semiconductor design
firm they've basically created a
software security business unit
and they have put together all these
types of
solutions that's another example of
traditional application security
yet another example is software
composition
analysis where you might have to use a
lot of third-party libraries in your
code
to get all kinds of functions done that
you want to build yourself
and and those libraries could have
vulnerabilities so what software
composition analysis
does is it figures out well what are all
the different say third-party
open source packages that you're using
and uh what are the vulnerabilities in
those open source packages so that you
could
make sure you keep your libraries up to
date blacked out as an example
laptop was also acquired by by synopsis
so this is what application security is
about
now the traditional model application
security has been
you know you write some code you then
test it you then fix it you then deploy
it
given the interest from industry
in speed and agility uh
the lines between development and
testing are getting
blurred with um with techniques
like devops and sec devops if you've
heard any of these
and so another approach a new approach
is to say
that instead of having these distinct
phases of development
testing fixing more development testing
fixing et cetera
a lot of companies have set up ci cd
pipelines continuous integration
continuous delivery pipelines where
what the developers are doing is uh
continuously rolling out new features
sometimes there's multiple recent
releases per day
and so the question is if you have this
kind of a environment how do you
change the way you approach uh security
testing well
the the approach is more of an approach
around
observability and it's
more constant so there's a whole variety
of
uh startups and tools uh contrast
security deep factor of assisting
that have focused on making sure
that you are always observing what's
running
in test and staging and in production
sometimes
to determine what vulnerabilities exist
so to to look at you know deep factor as
an example
what deep factor does is it it's
continuously running
and it's looking for all kinds of
vulnerability even when you're in test
and staging if some new
developer introduces a library that
wasn't getting used before
and there's some new process running
it'll it'll help identify that and
provide a prevent sensor and provide
absorptive observability
and visibility around that uh and i'll
show an example of uh
you know results for from deep factor
opsera is a is a new startup
that just launched earlier this year and
what they do is they will let you set up
your ci cd pipeline
in such a way so that you can just kind
of pick and choose what
not only tools you use like to use
github or
whatnot but it also lets you choose from
a whole bunch of different security
tools and
integrate uh statistics and monitoring
in dashboards so that you can
continuously see
how many vulnerabilities are in test and
stage and what that allows you to do
is for instance like only launch when i
only push out a new feature
when any security issues are have been
addressed
so uh to provide an example of
you know what these tools are doing you
know previously
one had to buy uh static analysis from
one vendor and then dynamic analysis
from another vendor and
you know uh whatnot and source com
source code composition analysis from
another vendor
and then kind of integrate them all
together and that in itself could cost
easily hundreds of thousands of dollars
for you know big software development
shops maybe not a big deal
but if you're a smaller or medium-sized
player well what do you do
well this uh slide shows an example of
some
uh results from from deep factor where
it's just continuously running and test
and sage and it tells you hey look
there's sensitive information
potentially a password that was found in
an
environment variable while the code was
was running
in addition there's a bunch of debian
libraries that have some
vulnerabilities jlubc and gcca you can
see those vulnerabilities there
and it also does some dynamic analysis
to identify that well there's an issue
with checking cross-site requests for
great tokens so so this is an
example of just a new theme where
there's more
startups more tools coming out that
provide
observability continuous observability
for
cicd pipelines instead of being in a
typical
uh dev test fix dev test fix
uh so you can pretty much do all the
same thing so that's application
security
i'll now hand it back over to dan to
chat about blockchains
okay so these days thanks neil so i
guess these days we have to uh
include blockchains in any security
discussions which is great blockchains
is an area that i that i really like
in fact we do a lot of our research in
black blockchains now
so i can tell you personally the reason
the reason it's exciting to me is
because there are so many
fascinating technical problems that are
associated with blockchain specifically
kind of new applications of cryptography
new applications of decentralized and
distributed systems and even new
questions
in economics and game theory so there's
like enormous amount of
research activity going on in the
blockchain space but it's not just a
research
effort there's actually this this thing
is real right and there's
hundreds of billions of dollars now uh
invested in various forms of
blockchains either in currencies or more
sophisticated assets
um i could talk forever about about
these blockchains this is kind of a huge
huge area
i think in the interest of time i'm
actually going to keep it somewhat short
so again if this is something you'd like
to learn more about you feel free to
reach out to me directly
or we i teach a quarter long course on
blockchains called cs251
which anyone is is welcome to register
and take it the course is available
online
um so what is all the excitement about
well most of the applications for
blockchain center around financial
in the financial space these are
financial applications
um so uh you know there are
cryptocurrencies like bitcoin that i'm
sure you've heard about
but there's a huge space out there of
decentralized finance application this
is called this is what's called d5
that is much much broader than just
bitcoin
and provides uh basically like a whole
set of new economic tools new financial
tools
that are available to anyone in the
world to use and these things simply
didn't exist before
so that's kind of where most of the
excitement is uh and i can tell you
that uh there's for example in countries
that have a non-stable currency
there's a lot of interest in saving
using bitcoin or putting one savings
into a stable currency like maker dao or
so on
uh so there's quite a lot of global
interest in this area
um so some some interesting developments
that are kind of relevant to you
is uh well recently large companies like
square and paypal
added direct customer supports for
buying cryptocurrencies
so for example if you uh use the square
cash app
you'll see that there's like a new if
you look at the bottom here bottom left
sorry bottom right
you'll see there's a new bitcoin tab
that allows people to directly buy
bitcoin from the square cash app
uh and the same thing with paypal and
apparently there's a lot of demand for
this so already
you sort of see these cryptocurrencies
uh going mainstream
in that the general public likes the
fact that they can interact with this
very sophisticated financial system they
can interact with it uh
quite easily and in many ways a lot a
lot more
it's a lot easier to interact with than
with the traditional financial system
what's interesting is both square and
paypal currently only support bitcoin
which is a little bit disappointing to
me uh in that there is a
there are a lot of other very high value
tools available in the blockchain space
like like ether for
the currency for ethereum or as i
mentioned before uh dye
the currency for maker dao which is a
stable currency so there are many other
tools
that are available that would have been
nice to see uh those being also
available to the public through these
uh very popular apps so that's one
development
that's happened the other thing so
obviously the other question is if
you're not in a financial space
should you care about these
cryptocurrencies and the answer is i
would like to say
is yes and one of the big things that
we're going to be seeing
is a huge interest from central banks
in deploying digital currencies yeah so
in one way or another these are going to
be related to blockchains and
cryptocurrencies
and so already there's a you know bank
of international
settlements has been putting out reports
very good reports
about the interest of central banks in
digital currencies
and in particular there's something like
40 central banks who are
uh playing with digital currencies in
one way or another of course as you know
the one that's
um most advanced right now is the bank
of china
people's bank of china which already has
um
a uh a project in in
in place and actually people are already
starting to use it
it's quite interesting so the digital e1
uh it's not
what we would call a traditional
cryptocurrencies in the traditional
sense
is that it doesn't satisfy the
properties of a digital currency
um or over cryptocurrency i should say
but it is definitely
a digitization of uh the local currency
and we're like very likely to see these
things happening in other parts of the
world
so if whether you're in a finance space
or whether you're just doing e-commerce
or
um any sort of applications that touches
money
you you should be aware of the fact that
uh digitization of the currency is
taking place
and um you know our financial rails are
going to be probably changing
dramatically
in the coming years like i said i can
talk about this forever but i think in
the interest of time maybe i'll leave it
here
if you want to learn more you know
please check out our
blockchain class it's called cs251 all
the material materials are available
online
and you're also very welcome to take the
course when it's offered
so neil back to you great thank you dan
okay so i'm going to chat about the last
category that we had on deck
network and infrastructure security of
all the categories that we've talked
about this is probably the
uh most traditional category probably
goes back
40 years or 34 years or so and so
things like firewalls both stateless and
stateful firewalls fit into this
category
you know every every i'd say seven or
eight years there's
uh you know a new next-gen set of
firewalls that come out you know the
initial set of firewalls
were stateless where it didn't uh where
it would only like looked at one packet
at a time
uh and then there were state full
firewalls which looked at streams of
packets to decide whether or not they
should say be allowed into the network
uh but the network infrastructure
security area has gotten
much more sophisticated uh over time and
it's also
grown there's been many many
subcategories so for instance
you know even just this year gartner
said that the
category of say network traffic analysis
tools
uh had become more sophisticated and
all these traffic analysis tools had not
only
been doing analysis but have started
detecting attacks and
responding to them and so they created a
new category called network detection
and response and
it deals with a whole bunch of threats
not just you know do you let packets in
or do you not let packets in
but these tools these days will in fact
look for
malware they'll look for communication
with
uh malicious urls so they'll look uh you
know deeply into
packets and deeply into payloads
you know there's a whole bunch of other
areas in this category so things like
network access control do i even allow a
device an endpoint device to communicate
on this network
how do i deal with distributed denial of
service attacks that also typically
falls within this category
uh intrusion detection prevention uh
going back to tools like uh bro that
came out of the research community
uh decades ago now uh you know are are
part of this network infrastructure
category so let me chat a little bit
about what's what's
what's new um given that there have been
a lot of uh ransomware attacks
especially ransomware
uh attacks that have been affecting
strings of hospitals i mean the last
thing that we need
in the in the midst of a pandemic
one of the one of the advantages of
using network based tools to do malware
detection
as opposed to endpoint based tools is
that if you can prevent malware from
even getting to an
end point and running on an endpoint
then the malware
first of all doesn't have the ability to
try to disable the
agent on the endpoint and number two
the malware doesn't have the ability to
try to affect
the detection capability um so so
uh you know these these detections are
happening
uh you know using more and more
artificial intelligence whether it's
machine learning whether it's deep
learning
deep learning is significantly changing
the detection rates of these tools you
know most
malware detection tools will
traditionally use signatures
um you know sequences of bytes in the
malware binaries and
known malware binaries to try to
identify them
attackers of course basically what
they'll do before
they release a new piece of malware is
they'll run it through all the existing
malware scanners until they come up with
a variant that isn't detected by anybody
and then they'll release those and so
it's really important to leverage
uh artificial intelligence deep learning
machine learning
to be able to identify samples of
malware that have just never never been
seen before
so using such approaches you can you can
achieve
uh detection rates of 99 and above
on unknown malware samples while
organizations like av test.org
have always looked at detection rates
in terms of known malware samples it's
the detection rate for unknown
malware samples that that's you know uh
arguably just as or more important
and so so by leveraging these kinds of
tools you can bring the the meantime the
detect
uh new such samples to milliseconds
instead of hours days and months
and uh you know there's a number of
companies in this space blue hexagon
cisco stealthwatch
extrahop um you know they're they're now
employing these kinds of tools uh
blue hexagon has for instance been doing
doing a great job and there's a
you know some some some new information
report that'll be coming up around that
but basically
uh you know a lot of the vendors in this
space
are bringing more network-based
detections
and using increased levels of
sophistications
uh to detect things even before they hit
end points
and so that's uh that's that's what's
been doing in the network and
infrastructure security
area one of the things that i wanted to
mention as we kind of tie
up is that there's a lot of cyber
security companies
out there but we need to continue to
innovate in the space
and uh you know the outcomes for
cyber security companies are generally
you know much better than another in
other verticals in fact the most likely
outcome
based on the study of over 3 900
funded cyber security companies from
data from pitchbook is that
over uh over 50 percent of them get
acquired so out of 3 900
companies under the past 15 years over
2000 of them
have been been acquired there's
relatively few that have gone out of
business
only five percent or less and
there's still a bunch that are privately
held some of these uh
will get acquired some of these will go
out of business and then they just
continue
on uh but uh you know this is a space
that is
ripe for innovation right for starting
new companies
uh if you if you're interested in
starting a new company in this space
please feel free to reach out to me i'd
love to learn more
um you know the the um
to just kind of summarize it uh you know
while the space is crowded and
fragmented
that there there there's always new
attacks being developed
uh as a result there's always new
defenses that we have to develop we have
to continue
raising the bar against attackers and i
noticed that there was one question that
came into the q a around okay
you know given the first slide that we
showed with all these different
categories how do you
how do you stitch together a
comprehensive information security
program
well i think the wrong answer is to try
to just like choose one tool in each of
these categories
and deploy them and hope you'll be
secure rather i think
in order to truly achieve security
you've got to look at your organization
what is your attack service what are the
threats that your organization faces
uh and who knows you might need three
defenses from say one particular
category because that's where the
threats are in your space and
you may not need defenses in other
categories um so so so
to achieve security it's it's not just
as simple as choosing one defense in
each category
rather there's a much more mindful and
thoughtful approach that can be
can can be uh used to to achieve
security
uh but but with that we hope that for
those of you that uh
haven't been in the cyber security field
you'll consider coming into the field
for those of you of you that are in the
field i hope you've learned at least one
new thing that you
haven't known before uh and it's an
exciting space so with that we'll take
we'll take questions
so with that uh let's go ahead and jump
into q a
uh i saw that we've lined up a few of
the questions
so i think it might be best to just jump
into those so
uh dan what do you think about the slow
migration to e2e encryption
is it why is it so slow is it just hard
or is it not being prioritized
oh yeah that's a great question so uh
right so you're asking i guess the the
the questions about end-to-end
encryption when why
why is it not here yet and the answer
actually is that we're getting there
right so end-to-end encryption is not
available for email
email is kind of an old protocol it's
very difficult to make changes to
because there's so many clients out
there so so with email
in fact end-to-end encryption is a bit
more problematic but if you look at all
of our chat systems now
like signal and and uh you know facebook
messenger and imessage and all that
um those are basically uh many of those
are end-to-end encrypted
so actually we're we're starting to get
there um
so yeah i i i'd say that uh
saying that uh we're not using engine
encryption is is kind of not quite uh
true anymore it's true that for email
it's not happening but an email
hopefully is not the
the going to be the prevalent mode of
communication in the future
good question great neil did you want to
add anything to that
no no i think uh dan covered that quite
well okay
uh so we also got some questions around
cloud security uh specifically around
key rotation
and a lot of people were excited about
that about that idea
um so is this something
for cloud native or architectures and
organizations is is this
an option uh is it possible do you
utilize updateable
encryption in all cloud architecture or
is there
is are there limitations to it yeah
that's again a really really good
question i'm glad uh
you guys uh picked up on that um so
first of all yeah it's a
it's a different way of doing encryption
so definitely a
really kind of exciting development um
let's see so not all data can be
encrypted in the cloud right if the
cloud needs to operate on the data if
you need to do
all sorts of processing of the data in
the cloud it's actually a little bit
difficult
to store the data encrypted but if
you're mostly using the cloud
the cloud just for data retrieval and
data storage
there it makes sense to actually keep
the data in the cloud encrypted
and once you do have the data in the
cloud encrypted you can use these
these uh updatable encryption mechanisms
to do key rotation
so what's defined what the research
community has done including kind of our
work
is define ways to do upgradeable
encryption
that are relatively efficient and
practical i think the next step that
will happen
is either a standardization body like
nist
or others will get involved in
standardizing these modes of encryption
or a company like amazon or maybe google
cloud
will go ahead and just implement one of
these one of these schemes and make them
available to you
so i would not suggest that
you kind of jump ahead and implement
upgradable encryption yourself
implementing cryptography as you
probably know is pretty
pretty tricky um and it's good to either
follow standards or let sort of uh large
crypto groups
that have a lot of experience with
implementations do it but it's something
that
you can you can ask for right so what i
wanted you to be aware of is that it can
be done now
um quite practically actually and so
it's up to you now to basically ask that
request that
from your cloud provider and if enough
customers request it of course they'll
go ahead and make that available
so yeah basically
what i wanted to make sure is that it
seems like the naive solutions don't
work
and as a result people just throw their
hands up and do nothing
and it's kind of important to understand
that with a bit more
sophisticated cryptography these things
can actually be done
so yeah it's a great question i'm really
glad you have so thank you
perfect thanks neil i think the next one
is for you or actually
you know both of you we've seen recently
just an increasing number of zero-day
attacks you know malware that we don't
know about until
suddenly you find out it's in your
software so what do you see the solution
to these kinds of zero-day or attacks
that are even if they're not zero-day
are being revealed by ethical hackers
before there's a solution implemented
sure i'd be happy to take that so you
know malware detection
was traditionally dependent upon
signatures
where someone uh when a new piece of
malware was found
they would uh extract a sequence of
bytes and
they would look for that sequence of
bytes in new
uh unknown samples and that approach
has proved to be you know fragile over
time and
doesn't have good detection right so
with all the uh new quote-unquote uh
you know zero-day vulnerabilities and
quote-unquote zero-day malware to use
the term zero day a little bit
the idea is how do you catch all the
malware that you've just that's never
been seen or observed before by anyone
and i think that the answer there
lies in artificial intelligence
techniques like
both machine learning uh supervised
learning as well as uh you know anomaly
detection what not
unsupervised learning what they're able
to do in at least the supervised cases
you know they look at
um hundreds of thousands of past samples
and they look at
tens of thousands of quote unquote
features
in any piece of uh known malware
and basically because there's such a
large diversity of things that
the algorithm is now looking for rather
than just a sequence of bytes
you have the capability and the
possibility by leveraging artificial
intelligence
to detect a whole bunch of previously
unknown malware even
when there's a first observation of a
completely new piece of malware
you can now detect it if you're using
appropriate artificial intelligence and
deep learning
uh techniques um so so so i i did i did
sacrifice a little bit of technical
accuracy in that explanation
but but hopefully um you know
the answer is clear you need to be
relying on
artificial intelligence much more
heavily as part of your detection
capability
to detect uh new unknown malware
variants
i think we could probably do a whole
other webinar just on the uses of
machine learning and ai and in security
i think maybe that's something that
would be uh relevant to this to this
audience
one thing that i uh wanted to add to
what neil said
is that there's a large field of machine
learning now called adversarial machine
learning
which is kind of at the intersection of
computer security and machine learning
and what it shows is that actually
machine learning algorithms
can be defeated quite easily in an
adversarial environment
yeah so if you train a machine learning
model to classify something
classify some to learn some class it's
actually quite easy
to design adversarial examples that
would cause the machine learning
algorithm the machine learning model
to misclassify so i i think
it actually would be interesting for us
to do a webinar on machine learning and
security
but i think that one has to be a little
bit careful in that these machine
learning algorithms
don't do very well in adversarial
environments yeah and we have many many
many examples of that now
um so yeah just wanted to add that to
keep to keep that in mind
yeah thanks dan after that a little bit
more as well you know basically i i
think that ai
raises the bar against the malware
authors but as dan said
uh the second that they start using
adversarial ai techniques
they're then able to evade uh even ai
based detection
so it is important that for any say
company that attempts to use machine
learning in malware detection
to assume that the environment is going
to be adversarial
um and uh you know you take appropriate
steps in
in instrumenting the algorithms
appropriately so that you don't assume
all the user input is good
but but i think that uh you know
leveraging ai and techniques to
defeat adversarial attacks against the
ai
uh you know is indeed the right
direction in raising the bar against the
attackers
perfect well that that's actually
probably a perfect ending point because
we don't have time to get to all the
questions and i want to be respectful of
everybody's
time but i think given the questions
that we're asking we're already thinking
about what the next webinar
should be and so i want to thank uh dan
binet and neil daswani again for joining
us today and giving this this excellent
webinar
on the cyber security market uh
so with that i want to thank everyone
again and thank you neil and dan
it's been a pleasure yeah thank you all
this was fun
thank you dan thank you pax
you